[موسيقى]
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 28 من
اعضاء حركه حماس بينهم خمسه من نوابها في
المجلس التشريعي الفلسطيني ياتي هذا في
سياق حمله اعتقالات واسعه تشنغ اسرائيل
بالضفه الغربيه منذ منتصف الشهر الجاري
شملت مئات المعتقلين من مختلف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفصائل
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما الذي تريد اسرائيل تحقيقه بشن
هذه الحمله الشرسه من الاعتقالات في الضفه
الغربيه وكيف يمكن ان تنعكس هذه الحمله
على مسار المصالحه الفلسطينيه في الظرف
الراهن
[موسيقى]
في سياق تفسيرها لحمله الاعتقالات الشرسه
التي اطلقتها ضد الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه قالت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان
هدف الحمله هو محاوله اعاده الهدوء الى
المنطقه تفسير لا تتفق معه اطراف فلسطينيه
ربطت بين ما اعتبرته خيبه اسرائيليه في
قطاع غزه وموجه الاعتقالات التي شملت حسب
بعض المصادر مئات الفلسطينيين من مختلف
فصائل لم يكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ينهي
عملياته العسكريه في غزه نزولا عند اتفاق
التهدئه حتى كانت قواته في الضفه الغربيه
تكثف من عمليه اعتقال بدات سلفا ضد نشطاء
الفلسطينيين معتقلون من مختلف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بينهم نواب في المجلس التشريعي
عن حركه حماس القى الجيش الاسرائيلي القبض
عليهم قائلا ان تهمتهم اساس تتمثل في
القيام بانشطه ارهابيه وعنيفه في الضفه
وان اعتقالهم انما يهدف لاعاده الهدوء في
المنطقه ربتت حماس هذه التطورات بما الت
اليه الامور في غزه مؤكده ان فشل تلبيب في
هجمتها على الحركه هناك جعلها تفكر في
التغطيه عليه باعتقالات تقول انها لن ترعب
الحركه ولن تستطيع ايقاف مسيرتها ولن
تستطيع ان تعيد للجيش الاسرائيلي هيبه
فقدها من وجهه نظر الحمساوي لا اله الا
الله قاومت غزه فداع لها الضفه بمسيرات
المسانده وبدا ملفتا ارتفاع منسوب التضامن
ليس فقط بين عامه الفلسطينيين وانما كذلك
بين قاده حركتي فتح وحماس بعد شهور من
جمود جهود المصالحه بينهما اوفد الرئيس
محمود عباس عضو اللجنه المركزيه لحركه فتح
نبيل شعث ليخطب في الغزيين بلغه افتقدوها
منذ زمن بارك انتصارهم واكد لهم ان هزيمه
الاحتلال تمر حتما بالوحده بين قوى الشعب
الفلسطيني ربما كان من المبكر الحديث عن
تحول نوعي في العلاقه بين فتح وحماس
فالباب مفتوح على مصرعيه حاليا للوقوف عند
المسافات القائمه بين حسابي الحقل والبيدر
لدى طرفي المواجهه احتفل الفلسطينيون بما
اعتبروه نصرا لمقاومه واجهت عدوها
المتفوقه عده وعتادا مواجهه الند للند اما
في اسرائيل فقد اشتد الجدل بين من رمى
الحمله العسكريه بالشل الريع واستطلاعات
راي اشارت الى ارتفاع شعبيه نتنياهو
المقبل على انتخابات تشريعيه وشيكه مناسبه
مفصليه في الساحه السياسيه الاسرائيليه
يدرك اليمين الاسرائيلي بمختلف تعبيراته
ان اذن كثير من
الناخبين تطرب لسماع اخبار الهجمات
العسكريه والاعتقالات الواسعه فكان عمود
السحاب في غزه وكانت الاعتقالات في الضفه
الغربيه تقول قراءات في مسار السياسه
الاسرائيليه هذه
الايام لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام
الله قدور فارس القيادي في حركه فتح ورئيس
نادي الاسير الفلسطينيه ومن غزه مشير
المصري القيادي في حركه حماس كما نتوقع
بعد قليل ان ينضم الينا من القدس احمد
الطيبي رئيس كتله الحركه العربيه للتغيير
في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي وابدا بضيفي من رام
الله السيد قدوره فارس عن الح سبات
الاسرائيليه هذه الايام وهي تقوم بكل هذه
العمليات من الاعتقالات في الضفه
الغربيه يعني اولا الاعتقال واستمرار
حملات الاعتقال يمثل مكون اساسي في
استراتيجيه اسرائيل وهي تخوض حرب استنزاف
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ثانيا بعد انتهاء
العدوان على غزه وبعد الانتصار الذي سجلته
المقاومه اسرائيل فعلا تداري خيبتها
وتخاطب قطاعات يمينيه متطرفه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بانها بان في جعبتها المزيد
للتنكيل في الشعب الفلسطيني وهي فاتوره
انتخابيه الامر الاخر واظنه الاساسي هو في
الجوله الاخيره من الصراع مع الاحتلال بدا
واضحا ان الضفه الغربيه لو استمرت هذه
الحمله المجرمه على غزه ربما كانت ستكون
هناك انتفاضه حقيقيه يعني لو قارنا بين
عدوان 2008 2009 مع العدوان الاخير كانت
يعني وتيره تفاعل الشارع الفلسطيني في
الضفه الغربيه وفي القدس افضل بكثير من من
المرحله الاولى ولذلك اسرائيل قلقه فعلا
من ان يؤدي ذلك الى انتفاضه جديده في في
في الضفه الغربيه وفي القدس وتعتقد ان
حمله الاعتقالات يمكن ان تدرا عنها خطر
كهذا السيد المشير المصري في غزه ماذا عن
انتم في حماس كيف تنظرون الى هذه
الاعتقالات خاصه وانها تشمل مختلف الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحيه
لك ولضيفك ولجميع
المشاهدين اعتقد ان الهدف من وراء هذه
الاعتقالات التي زادت وتيرتها في الاونه
الاخيره بخاصه بعد الانتصار الذي حققته
المقاومه في غزه هي محاوله صهيونيه لترميم
هزيمته ولتحسين صورته
لايضاح نصر موهوم ومصطنع بعد ان فشل عدو
الصهيون في تحقيقه في قطاع غزه ورد خ
لشروط المقاومه يحاول ان يتعنت على ابناء
شعبنا في الضفه الغربيه وبخاصه القيادات
ومنهم نواب حركه حماس في الضفه الغربيه
والعديد من الفصائل ال الفلسطينيه وثالثا
هي محاوله الصهيونيه لارباك الساحه
الفلسطينيه ولخلق الاوراق فيها والخشيه من
ان تتوحد الضفه ال الغربيه في ميدان
مواجهه العدو الصهيوني كما توحدت غزه في
اداره المعركه في حجاره السجين
وحققت الانتصار وافلت اهداف العدو
الصهيوني سيد قدوره فارس لطالما كانت هناك
محاولات تكريس الصوره التاليه ان ما يجري
في غزه لا علاقه له بما يجري في الضفه
الغربيه ما جرى هذه المره في غزه وهذه
الحمله من الاعتقالات الشرسه كما ذكرت
لمختلف الفصائل الفلسطينيه ما الذي اضافته
للمشهد
الفلسطيني نحن نعلم ولا نريد يعني ان يكون
سلوك الاحتلال العدواني بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني يعلمنا باننا شعب واحد اسرائيل
ارادت خلال السنوات الماضيه
اي يعني ان تجعل من الضفه الغربيه والقدس
كيان مختلف تماما عن الكيان القائم في
قطاع غزه الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى الرغم من
ال من الحاله الماساويه التي نعيشها في ظل
الانقسام لم نفقد البوصله وكلنا يعلم
واعتقد ان الخطاب الصادر عن كل عن مختلف
القيادات في كل التنظيمات بعد الانجاز
الكبير الذي تحقق بانهاء هذا العدوان
الهامد على قطاع غزه هو مؤشر على ان الشعب
الفلسطيني لم يضل طريقه ولم يفقد
بوصلته نحو اهدافه الوطنيه بشكل عام وان
الرافعه الاساسيه ل لتحقيق الانتصار على
الاحتلال واقامه الدوله هو الوحده ارجو ان
تستثمر يعني حاله ال تسامي والارتقاء التي
تمت يعني على الصعيد الروحي والفكري
والمعنوي ان تستثمر في تحقيق انجاز ملح
وضروري هو وضع اليات لتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه
بشان يعني المصالحه الوطنيه والتوصل الى
استراتيجيه عم هذا هذا هو محونا الثاني في
هذه الحلقه من وراء الخبر عن العلاقه بين
ما يجري وبين هذا المشروع هذا الدافع نحو
الحديث و هل توفرت شروط المصالحه
الفلسطينيه الفلسطين ولكن قبل ذلك الان
جهز معنا ضيفنا من القدس السيد احمد
الطيبي رئيس كتله الحركه العربيه للتغيير
في الكنيست الاسرائيل دكتور احمد عن هذه
الحمله من الاعتقالات الاسرائيليه في صفوف
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه كيف
تراها هي ليست مفاجئه هذا هو السلوك
الاسرائيلي التقليدي خلال كل عدو وبعد كل
عدوان واحيانا
قبل خطوات عدوانيه من هذا القبيل ايضا في
2009 بعد العدوان كان في هناك حمله اعتقال
ولكن هذه المره اعتقد
ان
شعور الاحباط الاسرائيلي من جهه
وهناك من قدر قرا امكانيه وشعر بامكانيه
التلاحم والتقارب الداخلي الفلسطيني واراد
ان يقطع
الطريق عليها اراد ان يعطي اشاره لانه لا
احد يتهم هؤلاء النواب او هؤلاء المعتقلين
حتى من اعتقلهم قوات الاحتلال لم يصدر اي
بيان انهم هؤلاء خططوا لما هم يسمون ارهاب
او عمليات ارهابيه انها اعتقالات احتلال
وقائيه لمنع امكانيه مثل
هذا التقارب
والمصالحه
هناك مصلحه لاسرائيل بان لا تتم مثل هذه
المصالحه ولذلك نحن نقول انه اذا كان
تفسيرنا هو هذا واذا كان هذا هو الدافع
الاسرائيلي لقطع الطريق على
ترجمه ما اسماه اخي قدوره هذا التلاحم
والتناغم
الفلسطيني الداخلي الى وحده الى
انجاز نوع او حد ادنى من الوحده مش بس
الكلاميه وحده حقيقيه
لماذا لا نتحدى هذا الاحتلال ونتحدى الذات
الفلسطينيه المنقسمه طيب دكتور دكتور
احمدم في ظل ما وصفته الان في ظل هذا
المناخ
الايجابي فيما يتعلق بالمناخ الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني تحديدا هل توفرت شروط بناء
قاعده للتوافق الفلسطيني
برايك
هذه القاعده
موجوده من زمان كما يقال
وانا ك ممثل لفلسطيني 48 وكمن يشعر بالحزن
والاحباط والغضب واحيانا يسمحوا لي
الاخوان الخجل من حاله الانقسام
الفلسطينيه لا ارى سببا مقنعا لعدم التوصل
بعد ان تم توقيع اتفاق مصالحه واحد واثنين
وثلاثه واربعه يكفي بمعنى ان الظروف مهيئه
التصريحات بهذا الاتجاه
الشارع جاهز
مطالب بهذه الخطوه والتحدي الكبير ععد عن
الانقسام للطرفين لل فصيلين لفتح وحماس هو
الاحتلال انظر ماذا يجري يعني وهذا
العدوان على شع بالاشاره الى الاحتلال
دكتور احمد بالاشاره الى الاحتلال ان كان
الهدف الاسرائيلي من هذه التقالات الشرسه
هو الوقوف او خلط الاوراق امام اي محاوله
للمصالحه الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه هل
باعتقادك اثمرت شيء او اثمر شيء او نجح
الاحتلال في هذه
الخطوه لا هذه خطوات لا تمنع شعوب ولا
تمنع
قيادات مخلصه من التوصل الى اتفاق السبب
الثاني وقد ويجب ان نقوله هي عمليه
انتقاميه هي انتقام من حركه حماس يعني
ايه
الاحباط السياسي ما بعد انتهاء العدوان
يؤدي الى اتخاذ مثل هذه ال الخطوات ايه
مثل التنكيل بالناس على الحواجز مثل
اعتقال قيادات حماس اعضاء مجلس تشريعي هذه
خطوات انتقاميه وهي خطوات تافهه صغيره مع
رفضنا الكامل يعني ب بحجم الشعوب هي خطوات
تافهه من المحتل يجب الا تكون بمستوى منع
كما تفضلت امكانيه منع التوصل الى اتفاق
والى وحده الرد الاقوى على نتنياهو براك
وليبرمان هؤلاء الذين خرجوا في هذا
العدوان اللي انا
سميته حرب سلامه الصندوق صندوق الاقتراع
القصد عندما كان الدم الفلسطيني وقودا في
هذه الحمله الانتخابيه هو هذا التلاحم
وهذا
وهذه عن هذا التلاحم دكتور اح عن هذا
التلحم في الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه سوف
نتناول هل توفرت الشروط في ظل كل هذه
المتغيرات
الاقليميه والدوليه والاشارات الايجابيه
الصادره سواء من قطاع غزه او من الضفه
الغربيه للوصول الى مصالحه فلسطينيه
فلسطينيه حقيقيه بعد
الفاصل بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي نتناول
فيها دوافع حمله الاعتقالات الت تشنها
اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه وانعكاساتها
المحتمله على التقارب بين الفلسطينيين
واجدد تحيه بضيوفي في غزه ورام الله وكذلك
في القطس وتوجه الى غزه حيث يوجد مشير
المصري القيادي في حما في حركه حماس سيد
مشير باعتقادكم هل الان توفرت عوامل ان
تكون هناك وحده فلسطينيه فلسطينيه حقيقيه
تختلف عن عن كل ما جرى من
قبل انا اعتقد ان الفرصه الان سانحه اي
بالتاكيد على وحده الدم والهدف والمصير
الذي تلاحم فيه الشعب الفلسطيني حاله ال
الوحده التي ربما كانت غير مسبوقه في قطاع
غزه سواء في الميدان في اداره المعركه مع
العدو الصهيوني او الحاله السياسيه تشابك
الايدي السياسيه ربما لاول مره وهي تعلن
هذا ال الانتصار وثانيا النفير العام الذي
كان في الضفه الغربيه نصره لغزه وكان خشيه
الاحتلال بان يتحول هذا النفير الى
انتفاضه والى بدايه معركه ومقاومه مع
العدو الصهيوني والنقطه الثالثه اعتقد
المظله العربيه الامنه الان في مصر وبخاصه
بعد ان تحولت مصر الى مصر الثوره ومصر
الجديده وبالتالي يمكن ان ان نذهب ونحن
مطمئنون الى رعايه متوازنه ورعايه امنه
لموضوع المصالحه وان اعتقد ان الرد الابلغ
على هذا هذه الحرب الصهيونيه ضد قطاع غزه
وهذه الاعتقالات في الضفه الغربيه هو
المصارعه نحو المصالحه وعلى الخيار الذي
توحد عليه شعب الفلسطيني بشكل غير مسبوق
وهو خيار المقاومه خيار الصمود والتحدي
خيار التمسك بالحقوق والثوابت الفلسطينيه
لان ما دون ذلك هو محل خلاف لكن اعتقد ان
المقاومه والحقوق والثوابت هي محل اجماع
فلسطيني وعلى وعلى هذا اساس يمكن ان نتوحد
وان نشكل القاعده الصلبه ولكن س سيد مشير
هذه عوامل اغلبها كانت دائما موجوده
والقضيه الفلسطينيه عمرها من عمر الدهر ما
الذي اختلف هذه المره حتى يصبح هذا الكلام
له وقع وليس مجرد انطباع ايجابي نتيجه
ظروف ايجابيه سيزول مع اول محك بين
الطرفين انا اعتقد اخي الكريم بان حاله
الانسجام وحاله ال الوفاق اليوم امام
مواجهه العدو الصهيوني الذي يستهدف الكل
الفلسطيني الان هي حاله اليوم تعززت
وترسخت من خلال ال من خلال وقوف قطاع غزه
مع الضفه الغربيه وهكذا العكس وهذه اللحمه
التي ربما في معركه الفرقان وفي حرب عام
2008 2009 لم تكن بهذا الشكل وهذا
بالتاكيد ارخى بضلال ايجابيه ما بين غزه
والضفه ال غربيه وبخاصه بين حركتي حماس
وفتح واعتقد انه من المفترض ان يتوكل
الاخوه المصريون كما وعدوا بان يدعوا الى
جوله جديده من الحوار الفلسطيني واعتقد ان
المطلوب هو مواجهه الفيتو الامريكي
والصهيوني الرافض المصالحه الاحتلال لم
يرق له هذا التقارب بين غزه والضفه غربيه
وهذا النفير المشترك والمواجهه المشتركه
للعدو الصهيوني وبالتالي حاول ان يضرب هذه
الوحده وهذا التقارب والرد الابلغ على ذلك
هو ان نكسر هذا الفيتو الرافض لمصالحه
وكذلك التهديد الامريكي للتقارب في
المصالحه فلين سيد قدور فارس بعض التحاليل
تذهب للاتي هناك فعلا مناخ ايجابي فلسطيني
فلسطيني وتغير على المستوى الاقليمي وكذلك
المستوى الدولي ولكن ستدعم هذه الايجابيه
بذهاب الرئييس الفلسطيني الى الامم
المتحده والمطالبه
بفلسطين دوله غير عضو في الامم
المتحده او بصفه في الامم المتحده الى اي
مدى هذا التحليل دقيق في الربط باحداث
انتصار اخر بانتصار الذي جرى في غزه
وبالتالي تكون هناك قاعده جيده للحوار
الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني نعم هذا صحيح ويعني لعل الاخوه
في حركه حماس اعتمدوا في الاونه الاخيره
وتحديدا بعد انتصار المقاومه الاخير
اعتمدوا خطابا جديدا بشان التوجه للامم
المتحده المتحده
وهم يروا كما نرى نحن ان الامم المتحده هي
جبهه اخرى يخوض فيها الشعب الفلسطيني
معركه في مواجهه الاحتلال كما يعلم
الجميع اسرائيل استخدمت كل طاقتها وسخرت
كل امكانياتها من اجل ممارسه ضغط على
القياده الفلسطينيه حتى لا تواصل مسعاها
وكذلك الولايات المتحده عبرت عن عن موقف
متماثل تماما مع موقف اسرائيل وبالتالي
نحن في جبهه
المواجهه يعني الميدانيه على الارض كنا
معا في جبهه العمل السياسي يجب ان نكون
معا خطابنا وحوار يفترض ان يرتقي لمستوى
تضحيات الشعب الفلسطيني واضافه الى ذلك
هناك مناخ عربي يعني اتفق مع الاخ مشير ان
ال المتغيرات حولنا ستكون عامل حاسم
وايجابي نحو انجاز المصالحه ان شاء الله
يتحقق انجاز اضافي خلال ال الفتره القريبه
المقبله ليتبعه الانجاز الكبير الذي
ينتظره الشعب الفلسطيني وانا اعتقد باننا
يجب ان لا نغرق في تفاصيل القضايا المختلف
عليها يهمنا الان التوافق على برنامج
سياسي وكفاحي
وتنفيذ يعني البدء ببعض الخ الخطوات في
القضايا الاساسيه تنفيذها لندخل في طريق
ذو اتجاه واحد لا يمكن العوده منه وهو
الوصول في نا المطاف الى المصالحه دكتور
احمد عندما ماذا عن عن الجانب الاسرائيلي
عندما نتكلم عن اي سعي عن توفير اي شروط
او ظروف من اجل مصالحه فلسطينيه فلسطينيه
ماذا عن الجانب الاسرائيلي في
ذلك يعني انا اليوم وامس سمعنا في
الاعلام تقديرات ومخاوف اسرائيليه من
اوساط حكوميه كبيره من انجاز هذه الوحده
انا افهم الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي يتخوف
لانه يريد ان يبقى الجسم الفلسطيني منقسم
ضعيف متفتت ولذلك سيضع العراقيل الواحد
تلو الاخر اعود واكرر على ما تفضلت به من
سؤال
حول الدبلوماسيه الفلسطينيه كرافد هام
الان ما بعد انتهاء العدوان والاحباط
الاسرائيلي من نتائج هذا العدوان
الدعم الفلسطيني لكل الفصائل والشارع لهذه
الخطوه هو تقريبا كامل وانا اريد ان اشيد
فيما قاله الدكتور موسى ابو مرزوق قبل عده
ايام داعما لهذا التحرك وما قاله الاخوه
في الجهاد الاسلامي ايضا وسائر الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في منظمه تحرير اذا هناك
اجماع على هذه خطوه التي تجسد حق فلسطيني
اساسي وهي
التي
يستهدفها الجانب الاسرائيلي
تحديدا الفاشي ليبرمان الذي يصفها بانها
ارهاب دبلوماسي على فكره لا يوجد بالعلوم
السياسيه ولا بالعلاقات الدوليه مثل هذا
الاصطلاح هذا
اصطلاح اسرائيلي غريب وتافه و لذلك انا
اقول كما توحد الجهد الفلسطيني والدم
الفلسطيني في غزه كل الفصائل دفعت الثمن
الشعب الفلسطيني دفع الثمن في عشرات من
المدنيين الابرياء نساء ورجال وشيوخ طيب
والفصائل الفلسطينيه بكاملها دفعت الثمن
اذا يجب ان يتوحدوا ايضا في دفع هذا الجهد
الدب التحد دكتور احمد التوحد يحتاج ايضا
الى الى الى الى الى خطه الى وجهه نظر
تتواكب مع ما جرى من متغير هنا اسال ضيفي
في غزه السيد مشير المصري بعد هذه الحاله
من الفرحه والاحساس بالانتصار في غزه هل
لكم تصور من اجل المضي بشكل واضح في مساله
المصالحه الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه وعدم
الوقوف كما ذكر ضيفي من رام الله السيد
قدوره فارس في او الايغال او التوغل كثيرا
في
التفاصيل انا اؤكد بان الاولويه لدى حركه
حماس في ه هذه المرحله هي وحده الشعب
الفلسطيني باعتبار ان المصالحه في نظر
حركه حماس هي خيار استراتيجي ولا بد منه
وان وحده الموقف الفلسطيني هو الكفيل
بالاختراق الدبلوماسي وهو الكفيل بمواجهه
كل التحديات التي تمر بها القضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي الوحده ينبغي ان تقدم
على اي تحرك سواء داخلي او خارجي ومن هنا
فان نظره حركه حماس ل المصالحه هو ان ان
نمضي وان نسير باتجاه تطبيق ما تمت
الاتفاق عليه لسنا بحاجه الى اتفاق جديد
ولسنا بحاجه الى جولات جديده من حوار
الفلسطيني ما تم توقيع عليه في اتفاق
القاهره اعتقد ان كل الاطراف مطالبه ان ان
تترجم وان تطبق هذا الاتفاق على ارض
الواقع وان يرى النور دون الاغراق في هذه
التفاصيل المطلوب الشروع مباشره بتشكيل
حكومه الوفاق الوطني الشروع مباشره بان
تجلس الهيئه القياديه لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وان نتوافق على استراتيجيه
وطنيه موحده قائمه على قاعده التمسك
بالحقوق والثوابت الفلسطينيه ونحن لمتلك
اوراق القوه مقدمت المقا التج فطين من غزه
مشير المصري القيادي في حركه حماس كما
اشكر ضيفي من رام الله قدوره فارس القيادي
في حركه فتح ورئيس نادي الاسير الفلسطيني
واشكر ضيفي من القدس الدكتور احمد الطيبي
رئيس كتله الحركه العربيه للتغيير في
الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
ن